the Internet has been teeming with fresh
allegations of ties between the Russian
government and ziplock bag full of pee
Donald Trump rumors are swirling about
everything from Russian server is
communicating with the Trump
Organization allegations that the
Kremlin is blackmailing him with a
secretly recorded sex tape of him in a
Russian orgy yuck well to be fair to be
fair he didn't know it'd be an orgy he
was just having sex with one Russian
woman and then there ended up being four
other women inside of her so these
rumors sound as of right now the FBI has
found no clear connection between Trump
and Russia the rumors have no hard proof
and it kind of feels like a last ditch
effort to throw anything imaginable at
him to see what sticks and don't get me
wrong he's still a glowering hemorrhoid
but all of this is distracting from the
stuff he actually does and also the
upcoming election so comedians since
we're not verifying our sources here and
throwing out wild things that have no
basis than anything what have you heard
about Donald Trump's connections to
Russia
Janet um I heard they have these totally
crazy slumber parties where Putin like
braids his comb-over eat ice cream right
out of Dana Gould
he loves Russia so much that once at the
Comedy Store he offered to Yakov
Smirnoff all right boys hey Putin gave
him a tour of his submarine and Trump
says it's huge
yeah